- [Narrator] Alarms.
There's the ones that wake
you up in the morning.
Telling you've got a message.
That your lunch is ready.
To close the fridge door.
Emails, phone calls, Skype calls.
Facebook message, turbulence, amber alert.
And one particular
researcher has created this.
(high-pitched beeping)
An alarm to stand out from the crowd.
(high pitched beeping)
An alarm to stop a head on car collision.
(loud smashing)
Her name is--
- I'm Carryl Baldwin.
- [Narrator] And she's--
- [Carryl] I am the Director
of the Human Factors
and Applied Cognition program
at George Mason University.
- [Narrator] So how do
you go about creating
one of the world's most annoying sounds?
- [Carryl] We started out by going out
and getting recordings of actual sounds
that were in automobiles currently.
Then we took those sounds back to the lab.
- [Narrator] Once they
collected the sounds,
it was time to test on people.
They created a system
where the listener could--
- [Carryl] Play a sound and
then put it in a category--
- [Narrator] That the
sound most represented.
(beeping)
Either a low urgency,
like a Facebook message.
A medium range urgency,
like a check engine alert.
And finally, a high level urgency like
an oncoming collision warning.
(high pitched beeping)
- [Carryl] And then from
there we set up a series
of driving simulator studies
and they're driving along
and they're doing another
task just to kind of give them
a distraction component and
then suddenly, unexpectedly,
the car that they're following
would brake suddenly
and we looked at their collision avoidance
response on the timing of that.
- [Narrator] They created
the perfect forward
collision warning alarm.
(high pitched beeping)
And this was really important because--
- [Carryl] We found that
the sounds being used
currently weren't perceived
as being very urgent.
You know, a poorly designed
sound can be more dangerous
than not having a warning at all.
- [Narrator] So thanks for using the most
annoying sound to keep us safe.